I'm a huge Wes Anderson fan and I loved
your work in Isle of dogs and it was a
voice over work and did you when you
were voicing it did you think to
yourself maybe I'll finally get the call
for Live Action
I did you're absolutely right Steve
there's no question about it when you
when you work with for on a tour like
that
um it is a big trust exercise and and uh
we did this movie coming up asteroid
City in Spain and it was it wasn't easy
work working for Wes is not easy it's
very detailed and very specific and so
you really have to really concentrate
hard
what offsets that is the Congeniality uh
and and the the togetherness of the
experience so we're all at this
five-star hotel in Spain and every
single night is a banquet every single
night you are exchanging thoughts and
laughter and someone brings a guitar and
you're singing and you're doing it's
just uh it's just so familial it's it's
like fulfilling an actor Dream Camp you
know it's like with it's just it's it's
really it was a really really great
experience albeit again the work was
very specific and very and very
difficult
were you when he finally called you or
texted you wherever you got the
information where you finally like were
you like finally
yeah you know and when someone like that
calls you know it's the same thing I I
did the same thing with with Tom Hanks
when he called for something it's like
yes and what am I doing so I say to Wes
Anderson yes uh what what is it you want
me to do you know and that's the way it
is for all the actors we kind of show up
and say what is it you want us how do
you want us to do this Wes makes a uh an
animatic and voices all the characters
in The animatic what he calls the
cartoon and he hands us he gets us the
and we so we watch it on a laptop when
we watch the entire movie that he voices
on a laptop and it's like oh got it I
see where you're going I see what you're
doing and let me see if I can hit that
Target the character you've already
created let me see if I can point my
arrow toward it and hit it bullseye